I'm really excited to introduce Phil and
Dave and we'll have a conversation about
just the amazing success that has been
Pokemon go a number of you have these
android phones that that we hand it out
you'll if you're not familiar with
Pokemon go you can actually find the app
on the phones as well let me just ask
the question how many folks in the room
do not know Pokemon go okay we got a
handful here how many folks in the room
are avid players okay larger group there
we go there little system cheapest looks
but there's no need for that so so Phil
can you tell everyone just a little bit
about what pokemon go is it's obviously
this amazing piece of technology this
amazing game but how do you guys think
about it niantic some of those you don't
know we started niantic as a small
little startup scout project within
google almost five years ago the goal of
that that organization was to create an
experience for people to try and get
them off of their couches and back in
the real world so they could experience
other people and new places that create
exploration apps ways for people to
discover new things about their
community what we found along the way so
we created two products nee so we
created one called field trip which is a
discovery app to tell you interesting
porky little facts about the world
around you usually in the location that
you're that you're standing and then we
created a game ingress which paired
primarily public artworks with with this
real world location-based game and it's
it essentially for those you haven't
played it it's a territory capture game
with the central peak point being these
public artworks and what we found along
the way was the people that were
actually playing the game were enamored
with the opportunity to explore and
learn about their location and that sort
of invigorated us following an April
Fool's joke at Google you'll capture all
the pokemon a Google map
back in 2014 we found out we thought
would be a great idea for a real
location based game and so we took the
same basic pokemon style capture your
Pokemon I'm activity and mapped it onto
the real world and lucky for us the
pokemon company was really receptive for
them this was like this was like the
reimagining the pokemon game actually
was what they originally had imagined
the pokemon game to be so adding the
augmented reality features to it was was
something really special for them that's
great did you did you have any inkling
and when you were creating the game and
architecting in what happy about how
successful it would be we had absolutely
no idea how successful it would be and I
think we have a chart so this chart
shows you what happened there's an
anecdote that we use is like people have
always asked us like when did you know
this is going to be huge and we knew
within the first six hours of launch in
Australia and New Zealand and what the
reason why it was we launch Australia
New Zealand with the expectation that
Australian New Zealand would be four
percent of our target audience and that
that's the bottom line to that graph
that's where we expected the system to
be operating the red line above it was
are our worst case scenario and that was
5x are nominal usage and in the first
six hours of our Australia New Zealand
launch we had already hit fifty percent
of our worst case that four percent of
our target was now five was now half of
five acts and and you can see the rocket
ship that happened after that I think
any I see Luke sitting in the audience
over here he's the director for customer
reliability engineering and I mean he
was there with us the whole time riding
this rocket ship although for us I think
it was more of a hair's on fire kind of
thing it was it was a spectacular ride
most people don't realize that the
engineering team that made all this
happen on our side I was for engineers
Wow and we work pretty much non-stop for
about six weeks to make this reality and
and it was always as
not only that for us the surreal pneus
was what was happening in the real world
while this was happening but the the
fact that every time I entered a hangout
you know all of us were just totally
fried and and on the other side of the
the wall and a google google side grows
about 40 people sitting on this on the
other side of the it's like that just
really helped us feel like we're going
to make it so that was really kind of
cool that's great so so Dave I'd
mentioned customer reliability engineers
before and Phil just talked about the 40
people on the other side but you did
tell us the CRE view of what Phil just
talked about crd view is like 20 minutes
I think after you launched somebody on
your team called actually called your
gear camera call it called Simon who
called us and said just an early heads
up like we'll see how this goes but this
is kind of trending what's the word
really upward so you might want to you
might want to pay attention and yeah and
it didn't take very long for everyone to
sort of figure out that ok time to get
going the funny thing was we had spent a
long time planning to announce this cre
thing to the world and it was we in we
had gotten all the people we needed to
of the team and all sort of the HR stuff
you have to do and we we were going to
meet for the first time july sixth and
start on this really hairy problem we
had planned and and and then pokémons go
launched July fifth and so you know we
started today early but it was fine but
it was but it was awesome validation
right because a thing only talking you
and I've talked about on thousand times
is this relationship that people have
with their cloud vendors is kind of
unfair in a way right they are giving up
control of their infrastructure and yeah
we're giving a lot of innovation and
speed and cost savings those are all
great things on paper but at three in
the morning when there's you know
trouble it feels super unfair and there
has to be this new model kind of this I
like to think of it sort of this new
social contract of shared fate and
shared responsibility we're like
Googlers or or or partners that we train
and certify which is a big part of the
growth of this
you don't have to be there with them at
three in the morning on the pagers in
the war rooms taking mutual
responsibility for the success not just
of our cloud but of their production
application so this was the first one
and actually it was as hard as it was it
was an awesome experience I wouldn't
want to do like four of them a month but
it was a wonderful four cells with you
on that as yeah oh yeah I mean it was it
was a great experience for us I mean
John has said this multiple times he's
the CEO for niantic that that I don't
think that without i'm pretty sure
without the the help of google through
throughout this that I think the entire
team at niantic would have imploded we
just didn't have the engineering
resources to make this thing happen and
knowing and we were testing we were
testing limits on not only our software
but their software as well these are
these are capabilities in these systems
that that had never been tested before I
mean the largest Cooper Nettie's cluster
in a multi cluster I remember trying to
spin that thing up when one night and we
were all just kind of freaking out
terrified but having everybody having
experts on both sides of the wall really
made this thing a success and really
really appreciative of it you know what
what it would impress me as as I was
hearing from Dave what was going on
behind the scenes is how quickly we're
able to start pivoting together from
let's fix the problems that we have and
let's get the scale out there to let's
anticipate what's going to happen can
you talk a little bit about that yeah
Luke actually has a great saying which I
love which is Luke wave yeah wave your
hair bukas which is that forecasts are
mostly useless but forecasting is
unbelievably helpful right just the
exercise of constantly revising how you
think things are going to grow and so
okay australia new zealand little choppy
there for a minute the US was a little
bit better we learned some stuff it
wasn't better and but by the by the time
we got ready to do Japan right so we're
going ahead of the wave by the time I
got ready to Japan which just had to go
right like you know in the Japanese
market the tolerance
for hiccups is much lower than in the US
market or even in Europe he probably had
kind of a good handle we had gotten
ahead of that wave and and that was the
thing this was the act of forecasting
and planning and going through the
operational rigor and really looking at
the scaling failure points and then all
the things you know kind of learn in the
last 15 years about what happens when
big systems go keeper Nova fast and how
do they break that's that that was I
think the thing really kind of that was
the linchpin of it yep yeah it was
awesome I mean it was I mean looking
back on it the experience was at times
it was disheartening I mean knowing that
we were only getting like three or four
hours of sleep and I rolling out of bed
onto your computer I remember going to a
swim meet one morning and then getting
paged and then waking up ed who thought
he got paged by Google heh sorry but it
was actually me calling him is this how
whacked out our world was for about four
to six weeks but in the end I think
because of all of this and getting the
system really stable even with the
growth we had planned every single
engineer on that server team was able to
take a two-week vacation so we managed
to survive that and the team is actually
fully recovered and I think the world is
a great place well it really is a
tremendous story of Pokemon go i think
the the engineering feat that you pulled
off of both combining the maps and geo
with cloud with the game designs with
the integration of a really iconic brand
and then scaling it to a level that is
really unprecedented in terms of how
quickly you did it it's really just an
amazing story and we appreciate being
part of it I got I got to statistics to
share the first one is that at the
beginning of September I don't know what
the number is now but we were over 500
million installs worldwide and we aren't
even launched worldwide yet and then the
second one is that at the beginning of
September Pokemon go players have walked
4.6 billion kilometers which is more
than half the distance between Earth
Pluto which is and there are just for
the record there are pokemon on Pluto is
what I'm hearing you say at the moment
okay so i mean its legend that's in 60
days so that's pretty phenomenal that's
just one of the great things about
working on stuff like this is seeing
people benefiting from it and in
creating a social interaction which is
really what we set out to do it's also
gotta be the world's most successful
fitness app I was just thinking that
that's right right now one of the
world's most successful games and one of
the world's most successful I think my
children got more vitamin D over three
weeks and will be terrific well thank
you very much we appreciate you the
partnership and you being here so
everyone please thank